[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance the White House continues to
deny that the attorney general's demand
for the resignations of all 46 incumbent
US attorneys around the country and the
subsequent optical disaster the firing
of New York's US Attorney Preet Bharara
was instigated by a paranoid Sean
Hannity TV segment demanding the
immediate purge of everybody in the
government who had worked for President
Obama the circumstantial evidence
however supports the theory that it was
Hannity's puppeteer hand up trumps back
and that circumstantial evidence
consists of the grim reality that we
have elected president Emily Litella if
you are too young she was the Saturday
Night Live little old lady character
portrayed by the late great Gilda Radner
who came on to give ludicrous editorial
replies during Weekend Update such as
I'm here tonight to speak out against
busting schoolchildren what's all this
fuss I keep hearing about saving Soviet
jewelry what's all this fuss I keep
hearing about endangered feces and they
would correct her and she'd say that's
very different and then pause and say
never mind
122 vicious prisoners released by the
Obama administration from Gitmo have
returned to the battlefield just another
terrible decision even the Fox News
segment that President Emily Litella got
that from did not mess that up
113 of the prisoners were actually
released by the Bush administration
nevermind
but Trump was watching not listening as
in February seemingly talking about
terrorism in Europe you look at what's
happening last night in Sweden Sweden
who would believe this Sweden they took
in large numbers that was so off that it
prompted the closest thing Trump has yet
made to an admission that he's ever
screwed anything up my statement as to
what's happening in Sweden was in
reference to a story that was broadcast
on Fox news concerning immigrants in
Sweden others have suggested that Trump
is a real-life equivalent of the Peter
Sellers character Chauncey Gardiner in
the extraordinary movie being there
Sellars portrayed a gardener who lived
entire life on the grounds of a rich
man's mansion and understood only two
things gardening and television
discovered he is mistaken for a
political savant and is soon consulting
the president who misunderstands the
platitudes of TV that sellers repeats as
deep subtle insight what Chauncey
Gardiner knew his television he could
recite all the commercials he was
listening Trump is just as much of a
television addict with just as little
connection to non television reality but
while he is ruling this country based
largely on what he sees on TV that
reinforces what he already saw on TV or
reinforces what he thinks he already saw
on TV he's not even paying attention to
the TV since the inauguration he has
tweeted about a minimum of 11 news
stories it seems fair to believe he saw
on television and gotten them wrong in
some way
besides the Swedish and get most stories
the women's March protesters why didn't
these people vote the so-called carnage
in Chicago the so-called expert who
could prove there were 3 million illegal
votes only the guy has never produced
the evidence that he's promised his
conclusion that all the protesters at
berkeley were paid thugs exaggerating
the target of a terrorist attack in
paris from the louvre mall to the louvre
museum his announcement although
protests at the republican town halls
had been planned by liberals that the
first time jeff sessions ever met the
russian ambassador it was arranged by
obama about arnold schwarzenegger
departure from the apprentice and add to
those the crazy obama tapped my phone
story he's president Emily Litella
Trump's first 279 non deleted tweets as
president are amazingly television
centric there were two in which he
congratulated himself on the TV ratings
of his inauguration 10 promoting the
broadcasts of TV interviews he has given
including the exact time the show would
air there are six that specifically
criticize CNN one that criticizes MSNBC
and 24 that refer imprecisely to media
fake news fake media or fake news media
including one about how after
called them all that and called them the
enemy of the American people quote is
amazing how rude they are and the number
of Trump tweets that include fox
graphics or images or congratulations to
Fox News on it's ratings or simple
statements tagged at Fox & Friends
as if he's grandpa yelling at the
television that's 12 tweets this is a
total of 54 tweets about TV or stuff he
kinda saw on TV I have invoked Saturday
Night Live and the film being there so
why not one more
in the other great speech in the
fantastic paddy Chayefsky moving Network
Peter Finch as Howard Beale reminds us
what television really is when the 12th
largest company in the world controls
the most awesome goddamn propaganda
force in the whole godless world who
knows what [ __ ] will be peddled for
truth on this network so listen to me
television is not the truth we're in the
boredom killing business we deal in
illusions man none of it is true but you
people sit there day after day night
after night all ages colors Creed's
we're all you know you're beginning to
believe the illusions we're spinning
here you're beginning to think the tube
is reality and that your own lives are
unreal you do whatever the tube tells
you you dress like the tube you eat like
the tube you raise your children like
the tube you even think like the tube
this is mass madness you maniacs in
God's name you people are the real thing
we are the illusions sound like anybody
we know so is there a solution to
President Emily Litella
I mean before he is impeached or
imprisoned or institutionalized well
years ago an unhappy CEO whose fourth
largest company in the world owned my
television network sat me down and
threatened to take the network off the
air I don't mean figuratively I mean
fire everybody at it pay us our full
contracts and shut the channel off
because a rival cable network was making
up stories about how this CEO personally
was selling material used
to make weapons with which American
servicemen were being killed the man
said his 80-something mother back in
Cincinnati watched the rival Network and
kept calling him up to yell at him about
his disloyalty and he had had enough so
I said politely that I thought he was
overreacting and maybe there was a
middle ground short of shuttering the
network that was finally making him a
reported hundred million dollars a year
in profit and he said like what and I
offered him a few ideas and then I
decided to point out to him how crazy
his idea was and I said it was exactly
this crazy how old did you say your
mother was again and I asked eighty
whatever he answered well if she's that
old she certainly wouldn't be able to
put up much of a fight if you sent one
of your guys to her house and pulled her
cable connection out of the wall the CEO
got furious then he laughed and then we
compromised but now I'm thinking maybe
this is the solution with Trump Bannon
and maybe a couple of trumps Renta cops
go in and pull all the goddamn cable out
of the White House before this bastard
kills us all because unlike Emily
Litella when Trump is told he has
misunderstood something he heard on TV
he does not say never mind
resist peace